philadelphia eagles
subject of significant speculation that
they would look at a quarterback with
the sixth overall pick in the draft they
removed that temptation
by dropping to 12. i can't help but
wonder whether they drop to 12 now so
they don't look at quarterbacks and
don't give in to the possibility of
finding a franchise guy to replace jalen
hurts there was a report by rob mahdi
the ap over the weekend there's no
consensus in the building in philly
regarding hertz i think the smart move
though is just like i said last year
with gardner minshew in jacksonville
give the guy a year to see what he can
become sure and if he becomes a
franchise guy great if he doesn't then
next year have this conversation about
what you may do with the high
first-round pick you inevitably will
earn so they pick up a future first
round pick they drop back by six and
they still have a fairly high pick
relative to their needs because a lot of
quarterbacks are going to go before 12.
so they're going to get somebody that
they feel good about at 12 and they pick
up a first round pick on top of it in
the process i i think that's right you
know i mean i mean first off this is a
team that we know has more than just
like one hole to fill uh that that's the
one thing i look at you know with them
at number six yeah it takes them out of
some of the more key players that might
have been talked about towards the top
of the draft but i think when you're a
team like the philadelphia eagles you
got to be real with yourself and go wait
we're more than one player away here you
know we we got to do something to to
help our whole football team and it's
going to be more than just one year of
of fixing our football team to think
that that's going to get the job done
and then we'll be back in the mix of
things 2022. no i don't i don't look at
it that way certainly not build your
football team i think that's what
philadelphia is probably taking the
approach with here you're right i mean
they're going to try to go with jalen
hurts we'll see where it goes there but
i think you know moving down acquiring
picks for this year and of course what
they do for themselves next year in the
2022 draft i mean that
it makes sense i think for their
football team and where they're at at
this current spot right now
i was always led to believe and i still
think this concept applies to some
extent the right time to trade a pick
is when the pick is on the clock
because then the team that acquires that
pick knows it's getting the player that
it covets from philly's perspective i
was curious why they would pull the
trigger on a trade now
for the sixth pick when they could have
auctioned it off instead when they were
on the clock but my understanding is
that premium of getting a second first
round pick and still being just on the
fringes of the top ten it's worth it to
go ahead and do it now and we talked
earlier miami knows they're getting a
great player there just like sam darnold
three years ago when the jets moved up
from six to three they didn't know they
were getting darnold they were content
to get darnold if that's who they got in
that spot the 49ers they know
who's gonna be gone or likely will be
gone they're content they're happy
they're thrilled to get who they're
gonna get at three same thing with the
dolphins at six and the eagles rather
than wait
do it now
get your first round pick
put it away file it away maybe you can
bring it back into play for some you
know swoop back into the bottom of round
one if there's an opportunity to do that
but the eagles realized that they would
get more of a premium by doing the move
now and giving the dolphins the
certainty they wanted by getting into
the six spot yeah yeah i mean it makes
it makes sense when you lay it out that
way uh i mean you know the eagles hey
they got some work cut out for them in
front of them i mean we know that just
would just it's across the board you
know defensive line
is is aging and nothing special there
linebackers
nothing special at all yeah darius slay
at corner okay but he's like you know on
the edge of the being done with the
prime of his career he's up there in
years the secondary needs a total
rebuild you know wide receiver i mean
yes they need that i mean there's really
not a really spot on the roster right
now where you don't look at the eagles
other than tackle because of they got
dillard and lane johnson other than that
you look at it and go they got to start
thinking about you know years for the
future improving the football team depth
everything like that so
howie roseman i think makes the
appropriate move and like you said he's
got lots of chips to cash in here to
play with to help build the football
team
yeah you're right though
where that team currently is look at it
right it's crazy i mean the the fall
from grace right
i still don't think we've seen anything
like it where all those key members of
the organization that won a super bowl
just three years ago are gone right and
uh they're only saving grace is they're
in such a bad division it's not as much
of a climb to get back to playoff
contention as it would be
elsewhere but what's going to be good
enough for eagles fans this year they
were up in arms last year
and and with jalen hurts we we really
don't know what he's going to be and
defenses haven't seen enough film to
come up with ways to stop him and he may
bash his head into a ceiling once
defenses know what he's all about chris
it's a real challenge for nick ciriani
and for hertz to be ready yeah for when
defenses can crack that code i think so
too i mean i'm interested to see i mean
you said it to start the segment i don't
think there was any consensus in that
building i had heard that there was a
lot of coaches that were going please
don't trade carson wentz but it's jalen
hurts and they got to make it work and
try to build something around him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports